if there isn't someone complaining and
there isn't really a serious public
health and safety issue why do they
spend so much of their time pursuing
these kinds of cases up in the
northernmost reaches of California's
Ventura County a two-lane rural road
known as highway 33 runs into the rugged
and mostly undeveloped transversed
mountain range though it's mostly raw
wilderness up there a few businesses
have long existed catering to the
adventurous sort willing to make the
long drive or hike but now the local
government is shutting these businesses
down one by one every little building i
haveea they started picking on heavily
the Pine Mountain Inn has been around
since the 1930s Tom Wolfe took over in
the 1970s and remembers the wild days of
hosting Hells Angels Hessians and
various other motorcycle clubs drinking
and kind of roughing us a little bit but
fun the wet t-shirt contest was really
turned into no t-shirt contest over the
years Pine Mountain Inn became more
family friendly as well hosting
gatherings of local community groups but
all that came to an end in 2002 when
wolf had to close the restaurant while
he recovered from a major heart attack
it was when he tried to reopen that he
ran into problems with the county they
were trying to close down and then
pretty much have closed down every
little bar every little homeowner no
matter how far back in the hills there
are and it's just continued to be worse
and worse the county said wolf couldn't
reopen the Pine Mountain and until he
took care of various code violations
including the presence of a mobile home
unpermitted solar panels and a chicken
house thank you they started about 13 or
14 items and then we got it down to like
three items and then it goes up to six
items then this is the way the game is
played it just never stops no matter how
hard wolf tried the county wouldn't stop
at one time even insisting that he take
down structures that never actually
existed they have claimed that I have a
violation of a chicken coop
on the property and since 76 when I
bought the property there has been no
particular chicken coop on the property
worst of all the Wolf's received a
letter informing them that their
property had been entirely rezone more
than 20 years ago without them even
knowing they want everybody out of here
and they wanted a complete open space
with nothing but deer and frogs and no
people
wolf is referring to Ventura County's
open space zoning designation which they
put in place to keep development from
occurring outside of so-called urban
centers but Pine Mountain in simply
doesn't fit in with that plan they have
been very successful in taking people's
property in a number of different ways
without compensation as long as they
don't take ownership of it
lynn jensen founded the coalition of
labor agriculture and business known as
collab in order to help property owners
organize and fight back against the
county for the most part the businesses
that were operating along the highway 33
are no longer in business this rezoning
is a way really to get around eminent
domain because eminent domain means you
give up your entire property and here
you only give up part part of your
rights so you get give up the right to
use your property
eminent domain gives governments the
power to take private property
if one the property will be used to
create a public goods such as a road and
to the owner of the property receives
just compensation but county officials
in Ventura and across the country are
finding ways to get around that through
zoning take the case of April and Bob
Hope who purchased the bed-and-breakfast
along Highway 33 called the wheel in
2000 they've never been able to open it
the county said that first it was the
waterline that was when they shut the
Barmes down was because of the water
line so they replaced the whole water
then they said we had no septic after
three years research I found it scanned
on the county website they had every
department hit as
Nations to make sure that they shut us
down and they pulled our liquor license
no one called the COS agency and said
we'll never open that bar for Bob Hope
the hopes are holding on to their
property but they aren't optimistic
about its future as a business they
don't do anything to help you know how
can we help you open the bar Bob how
would you how can we help you that will
never happen you know it's how can we do
anything so you'll never ever ever even
think about opening it they're supposed
to be for the public and they're not
doing that why is the county doing this
representatives from the Planning
Department and the county supervisors
office refused to speak with us on
camera we need to have regulation
there's no question about it but we want
those regulations to be based on reason
and not on control but what I'm saying
is a lot of these cases like Tom wolf
where there's nobody complaining about
him having a restaurant up there there's
really no apparent reason why they need
to be aggressive in terms of this Tom
wolf estimates he's already spent more
than 50 thousand dollars trying to get
in compliance and he vows to continue
the fight as his business and others are
steadily zoned out of existence I
thought it'd be easy to take care of I
truly believe that I could take care of
everything they got in front of me the
disappointing part is that nothing is
going to end it seems like